what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python basics tutorial video
this video is going to be discussing
another built-in function to Python
called exec which is short for execute
so what does exact do exec compiles and
evaluates whatever you pass through it
in string form so this is actually a
compiler in a compiler ok so python and
python and so notably this is actually
one of the most dangerous functions that
you can run on say a virtual private
server especially like a web server if
you have any sort of dynamic data being
passed through the exec function so
please keep that in mind now I don't
want to scare anybody off obviously I
mean any compiler on any machine is
dangerous ok so we can do lots of
dangerous things and bad things with
Python and we can do lots of beautiful
things with Python and really cool
things and the same is true with exec so
anyway let's jump in so first let's just
show a really simple example like we can
execute like we did before print um so
this works too so this works like eval
let's say ok so we can save and run that
and boom it printed and but if you
recall uh we weren't able to define like
something you know so we'll get to that
but first let's show an example where it
is not like eval
so let's say you have list string and
this string is going to be a string
first of all and it'll be a list so
we'll just put some put some numbers in
here doesn't really matter
so that's your list string now let's say
list string equals exact a list string
now if you recall doing this with eval
was successful but what happens when we
compile and evaluates what we pass
through so we could do something like
this let's print
Liz string so this says none okay so so
that does not work because what's
happening here is this is bit it's
almost like a compiler so like for
example it's this is on its own okay so
you're basically saying list string
equals the execution of this it's almost
like you're telling like it's it's like
you're telling Python that something
equals this right and now because it's
an interactive to a editor it's going to
put that under there but it would be
like this let's say instead of putting
it in there
when you say list string equals exact
list string it's almost like you're
saying it's like the action of that so
you get back none so what would you do
well what you could do is you can come
down here and you can say exact and
we'll we'll we'll keep these error
actually let's just do this we can say
exact and then we can do what we
couldn't do with eval and that is list
string will just say listen ring two
equals and then a list okay and then we
can go print list string two so actually
we never actually defined list string 2
except in the execution statement which
is a string so let's see if that works
hot-diggity that worked I don't know I
think it's really cool so then we can
step this up a little further and can we
do something like this
define test we'll call it and we could
get fancy but we'll just leave
everything on the same line and we'll
say this um oh we need to use single
quotes first of all and then we'll say
Oh
snip snap if that works then what we can
do is let's say see if we can call this
test function
Oh sniffs nap it worked
okay so we're even able to define new
functions in here now this should work
let's try the following let's say exact
and then we'll use triple quotes and
then define test2 and then print let's
see if multi-line works okay so this is
just a prettier way to execute something
and then we'll call test2 we'll see if
that works out for us and wouldn't you
know it that works too so pretty cool
that you're able to do do that so that's
X Zek if you have any questions or
comments on Exec please feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time